c'est dans six mois que les électeurs
américains seront appelés aux urnes et
donald trump ne l'a pas oublié en cette
période de crise sanitaire inédite le
président sortant garde en ligne de mire
son objectif de réélection alors qu'il
s'apprête à participer à une émission
sur la chaîne fox news pour répondre aux
questions de certains américains
le milliardaire s'est déjà montré
offensif sur twitter les démocrates
cherchent les ennuis comme toujours ils
ne font rien de constructif même en
temps de crise ils ne veulent pas blâmer
leurs vaches à lait la chine pour ce
fléau la chine blâme l'europe
le docteur fao çi va bientôt témoigné
devant le sénat c'est également sur son
réseau social favori qu'il a diffusé un
clip de campagne dans lequel il tire à
vue sur ses adversaires une vidéo qui se
termine avec un rendez vous fixé aux
américains celui de la date fatidique du
3 novembre prochain parallèlement le
locataire de la maison blanche souhaite
un retour au travail rapide des
sénateurs et des membres de la chambre
des représentants à washington
il affirme que la capacité de test est
suffisante pour assurer cette reprise
dans de bonnes conditions
li a une énorme capacité de dépistage du
coronavirus à washington pour les
sénateurs qui rentreront à capital il
lundi de même pour la chambre des
représentants qui devrait revenir mais
ne le fait pas à cause de nancy pelosi
la folle
le test d'abbott en cinq minutes sera
utilisé une proposition déclinée dans un
communiqué commun rarissime signé par la
démocrate et présidente de la chambre
des représentants nancy pelosi et mitch
mcconnell chef de la majorité
républicaine au sénat
le congrès reconnaissant envers
l'administration pour sa générosité de
déployer des capacités de test rapide
que 8,19 au capitole mais nous la
décline ou respectueux helmand pour le
moment les capacités de test de notre
pays continue de s'étendre à l'échelle
nationale et le congrès veut continuer à
diriger les ressources vers les
installations de première ligne où elles
peuvent faire le plus de biens et le
plus rapidement si les derniers bilans
quotidiens sont en légère baisse
outre-atlantique la situation sanitaire
reste très critique
les etats unis ont franchi la barre des
66 mille décès liés au corona virus